the first companies that come to mind
when you think about evs are tesla
rivian neo and lucid in terms of legacy
automakers volkswagen and ford are
making a pretty good push as well but
have you ever heard of a company called
byd
in the western world byd vehicles are
basically non-existent but in china byd
is a rather popular choice
byd isn't some new startup that was
created to leverage eb hype either byd
has actually been around since 1995 and
they've been involved in the automotive
business since 2003.
moreover unlike lucid and rivien who
have barely sold any cars byd is a
leader in ev sales
in fact within the first nine months of
2021 byd was only beaten out by tesla in
terms of ev deliveries
and they're currently the third largest
automotive company in the world by
market cap byd was actually the world's
largest ev company until tesla's recent
parabolic run
so here's the story of the eevee
behemoth that most of you have never
heard of
taking a look back the story of byd
dates back to a poor man named wang
chuan fu
wang was born on april 8 1966 in wube
county to a couple of poor farmers by
the time wang was a teenager both of his
parents had passed away and he was being
raised by his older brother and sister
for wang education was the only viable
path out of his situation so he attended
central south university where he
majored in chemistry he would instantly
turn around and get his masters from the
beijing non-ferrous research institute
in 1990. wang's initial goal was to
simply live a modest life by being a
good engineer and as such wayne became a
government researcher out of college he
worked at the general research institute
for non-ferrous metals where his job was
to research rare earth metals that could
be used in batteries he spent a couple
of years here but he found very low
fulfillment from this job
so in 1995 he teamed up with his cousin
liu jian yang to create byd
wang has never revealed the true meaning
of byd but he often jokes that it stands
for bring you dollars or build your
dreams
anyway byd wasn't an automotive company
from day one they were actually a
battery company
wang didn't have any connections or very
much brand power but what he did have
was expertise in batteries and given
that the laptop and mobile phone markets
were booming this knowledge was
extremely valuable byd started off by
producing batteries for small consumer
tech items like portable lights and
solar modules but as byd built a name
for themselves they were able to secure
larger jobs like producing batteries for
black and decker power tools nokia
handsets dell laptops and most
importantly the classic motorola razer
flip phone wang was able to build a
great relationship with motorola in fact
motorola was so impressed with byd that
the chairman of motorola awarded byd for
being an excellent supplier the road
wasn't all smooth though two notable
companies san your electric company and
sony would sue byd for intellectual
property theft byd would end up settling
with sanyo while the sony lawsuit was
rejected by a japanese court if you were
being sued by these guys it definitely
meant that you were a serious threat and
now that byd had built a name for
themselves wang decided to take the
company public in 2002 using their
raised funds wings purchased the
majority stake in a failing state-owned
car company called jian kinchwan auto
company and this marks the beginning of
byd auto
at first byd simply continued to sell
the flyer that gn had already developed
the flyer sold decently pulling in 20
000 sales per year but it wasn't
anything too crazy in the background
though byd was working hard to reverse
engineering every card they could get
their hands on they reverse engineered
engines molds motors entertainment
systems and wings s-class in other words
they were copying everything wang was
actually notorious for ordering large
quantities of parts from a notable
supplier and then never ordering again
because he had reverse engineered the
item and learned to build it himself
after a few years of copying i mean
reverse engineering byd came out with
their first model since the acquisition
called the f3 the front of the f3 looks
awfully similar to the 2003 toyota
corolla but despite their similar looks
the f3 was far cheaper which made it
much more attractive to many customers
over the next few years byd launched a
handful of cars like the f6 and
basically all of these were rip-offs of
different vehicles from toyota it should
also be noted that none of these
vehicles were electric
so byd wasn't really adding anything to
these vehicles other than a lower price
it wasn't until 2008 that byd jumped
into the eb market with the launch of
the f3 dm
the f3dm was a dual motor hybrid that
had a pure electric range of 60 miles
and it was actually the first plug-in
hybrid in the world but despite this
title consumers didn't really care
the f3 dm was basically just an electric
corolla and it didn't have the appeal
that eevees have today so the launch
ended up being a massive flop in both
china and internationally but despite
the underwhelming launch byd was
definitely onto something they were
targeting the utilitarian evie market
which is likely to become the biggest
portion of the ev industry over the next
few decades but in the late 2000s this
market simply wasn't developed yet most
utility car buyers prefer to stick with
cheaper gas alternatives and ev
customers were generally premium
consumers so byd was stuck in no man's
land wang didn't want to jump into the
luxury vehicle market though so he
loaded closer into who might be
interested in utility focused evs and
the answer was clear governments
governments don't care about buying cool
looking
they just want the most cost-effective
vehicle and if it's eco-friendly that's
just a bonus
so in 2009 byd started focusing their
efforts into mass producing electric
buses byd sold these buses to amsterdam
frankfurt los angeles and albuquerque
but this launch was actually quite
controversial albuquerque would end up
retraining the buses due to mechanical
issues
meanwhile california received several
complaints that the buses were
manufactured by people earning just 1.50
cents per hour
despite these concerns byd continued to
target the government by manufacturing
electric garbage trucks airport shuttles
tractors and mining trucks
around the same time warren buffett
would invest 232 million dollars into
byd in 2008.
all of this extra interest combined with
their government endeavors allowed byd
to reach 500 000 deliveries by 2010. to
put that in perspective tesla didn't
reach that figure until 10 years later
in 2020
but unlike tesla who was blasting past
that number byd has been stuck at half a
million for a decade
while a decade of no sales growth sounds
really bad from the surface it's
actually not too bad in byd's case
wang figured that the utility consumer
eb market still had years if not decades
to develop
i mean even now what 7 30 000 evs aren't
that common so wang decided to simply
maintain what byd was doing and instead
focused their effort into building a
real brand
up until then byd was really just a
chinese knockoff that people only bought
for the price but this would all change
with byd second generation cars
the first of the second gen vehicles was
the bydkin hybrid which debuted in 2013
just by looking at it you can see that
this was nothing like byd's older
vehicles the kin wasn't a super slick
vehicle or anything but for the first
time it was original aside from its
unique look the kin was also quite
affordable the kin wasn't able to live
up to byd's promised launch price of
just under 30 thousand dollars but it
did launch for thirty five thousand
dollars which is still cheaper than the
model three today following the kin byd
came out with the u1 in march of 2016.
the yuan was offered as a compact
crossover suv that was offered as a
hybrid and as a full ev
the hybrid version cost between thirty
two thousand dollars and thirty eight
thousand dollars so still under that 40k
mark both the can and yuan were solid
vehicles but by far their biggest jump
forward came with the han which was
released in july of 2020.
the haunt instantly sticks out as a
modern dv with its sleek design but not
only does it look good it's also quite
affordable the standard range comes with
314 miles of range and only costs 33 730
you can also get the extended range
which comes with 376 miles of range and
cost 36 540
byd quickly followed up the han with
this leak suv called the song in
september of 2020. the song also boasts
a range above 300 miles and comes in
under 40k
so though by these sales have remained
stagnant for a decade i think we'd agree
that byd is a completely different
company today than they were in 2010.
as for byd today i believe that they're
on the cusp of a massive boom in july
the han crossed 100 000 deliveries and i
don't really see anything stopping them
from reaching millions
also byd formed a partnership with
toyota two years ago originally it
seemed like they were just going to
manufacture some models together but
they actually ended up creating a new
car company called byd toyota in april
of 2020.
it's not clear when they launched their
first car but it should be within the
next few years as nine of them are new
to the car business
in terms of international expansion byd
does have some presence within latin
america and some scandinavian countries
but the vast majority of their business
comes from china
wang does eventually want to spend more
time on the western market with this
long-term goal of being 20 to 30 percent
of sales coming from outside china but
even if that doesn't materialize it's
not that big of a deal given the
strength of the chinese eevee market the
ccp has made some super questionable
moves in the past but their embracement
of evs is definitely not one of them
experts predict that as much as 40 of
chinese vehicles could be electric by
2030. considering this it wouldn't be
that surprising to see byd overtake
toyota within this decade but it would
be extremely ironic byd went from
knocking out toyota to partnering with
toyota to overtaking toyota as for wing
his net worth comes in at about 25
billion dollars which puts him
comfortably within the top 100 richest
people in the world and i think wang
more than deserves all of it given that
byd is one of the only companies in the
eb space that not only has hype but also
results were you guys familiar with byd
comment that down below also drop a like
if you think that legacy automakers
should get more serious about evs and of
course consider joining our discord
community to suggest futurity ideas and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm ari and i'll see you guys on
the next one